we were making nine dollars on a
thousand views this year and we only had
a hundred thousand but next year we're
gonna have 200 000 next year 300 000
like this is gonna be a this is like oil
we just hit a well this would be a huge
business turned out the difference
between attention and oil is that oil is
scarce oil is a limited resource right I
mean like you know like Bitcoin in fact
the core the you know the thing that
makes Commodities valuable is that
they're scarce and attention did not
turn out to be scarce attention turned
out to be nearly infinite and the scale
of platforms like Google and Twitter
meant that even a publisher that got an
enormous amount of eyeballs and
attention like BuzzFeed couldn't support
quality journalism
[Music]
all right guys bang bang I've got Ben
here with me uh Ben you wrote a brand
new book traffic genius rivalry and
delusion in the billion dollar race to
go viral it seems like that's the whole
name of the game today in the media is
just like go viral get clicks at least
that is from people outside of the media
looking in how do you think about you
know how much of media today is actually
just trying to go viral and get clicks
versus uh what I think maybe is the
nostalgic like true journalism hey let's
go find truth and say the things that
speak you know kind of Truth to power
you know I think it's changing a lot and
I mean the book tells the story of these
people in downtown Manhattan in the
neighborhood I'm in now you know in the
early 2000s places like Gawker BuzzFeed
were they like I mean it was and you
remember this but it was early day like
it was the first time you could really
see you had this website you could see
each visitor you could see who was
reading it and it changed how people
thought about media I mean everybody had
always wanted to be read but suddenly it
was like you were flying with
instruments you could see exactly what
was happening and everybody wanted to
get connected to Their audience and
suddenly you were right up in the face
of your audience of people talking back
to you all the time and I do think it
like deeply deeply changed media I mean
if you look at them the sort of
explosion of social media had exchange
Society but I also think I mean it's
interesting I mean I think people got
sick of it I mean I think the sort of
way you talk about chasing clicks and
virality you know there was a period
where that felt fun and exciting which
is a little hard to remember and I think
people now feel that they're that
they're they're being kind of
manipulated by algorithms that they
don't really there's so much incoming
the they don't know what to trust and I
actually think there's a real shift away
from
from that moment which you know I've
spent a lot of time thinking about I can
talk about a lot more into a new moment
where people are looking for like
individual trusted voices I mean
podcasts like this are a big part of
that actually
um newsletters like we do are a big part
of that
so I think I think actually the audience
is to somebody kind of caught on to that
sense that media companies are trying to
manipulate them trying to get clicks and
are sick of it so this whole idea of
like attention is the new oil what I
always kind of default to is
um people definitely hear that and they
think kind of negatively about it
because of the number of things that
you're talking about but they blame
media companies and I've always wondered
like how much of it is like a media
business and the incentives within those
types of organizations versus just like
no everyone's trying to get attention
like if you have a Twitter account
you're trying to go viral right if you
have a a sub stack you're trying to go
viral if you're just like a dude on the
street with a sign like you're kind of
trying to go viral right is that like
just a human nature thing or is there
something inherent about like a media
business and the incentives there that
kind of change or or maybe put it on
steroids
well I think these big platforms Twitter
and Facebook first of all but in other
areas Pinterest was part of that there
used to be something called StumbleUpon
if you remember you know and now there's
a number of other smaller ones you know
Reddit I mean I think there's have you
know maybe everybody wanted attention
but everybody did not have access to the
attention of everyone in the entire
world and I think you know in the sort
of peak peak days of Facebook like when
I was working for BuzzFeed in 2015 we
published this um this picture of a
dress that could either have been white
and gold or blue and black if you recall
and everyone in the world saw it within
you know an hour I remember at a
colleague I was in New York you know my
colleague was like this is crazy we
should publish it she said a woman had
said a woman who'd been at this wedding
sends it to BuzzFeed and says my mom and
I are arguing about what color this
dress is and this weird bad photo I took
and then we were arguing about it and we
post it
Mike another colleague members in
Jakarta that day and an hour later in
Jakarta everybody's arguing about it I
mean it was this instant moment of
global culture and actually it was
virality on a scale like we used to
think and we think things are really
going viral they're not like that
anymore like nothing's like that anymore
and in fact remember we were so proud we
thought it was cool like it was just a
fun sweet silly thing and Jonah pretty
the CEO of BuzzFeed and this is sort of
one of the things of the book you know
soon after that ran into a senior person
at Facebook and basically said wasn't
that cool
and they were like we're not sure that
was so cool like how often do you think
we should let that happen
and we were like right this is something
they were letting happen and B they're
getting a little scared about the SK
about the loss of control of their own
platform the sense that anything could
just take it over instantly and I
actually think you know one of the
things really I think the sort of purest
sort of viral scale particularly for
kind of news information conversation
ideas even probably like peaked in 2017
and I think a lot of I mean a lot of
people have left those platforms Twitter
Facebook for
you know particularly again I'm talking
about kind of news and information like
Tick Tock is obviously this huge
entertainment space but for podcasts
four newsletters four more controlled
spaces where they're not
just assaulted by a zillion people all
of them trying to go viral with some
thread and are in a more authentic
conversation and
and I think another thing that people
found both individuals and certainly
media companies is that attention turned
out not to be like oil we all thought in
like 2005 when we were you know when you
were getting a nine dollar CPM and you
were like this is just the beginning we
you know we were making nine dollars on
a thousand views in this year and we
only had a hundred thousand but next
year we're gonna have two hundred
thousand next year 300 000 like this is
going to be a this is like oil and we
just hit a well this would be a huge
business
turned out the difference between the
tension and oil is that oil is scarce
oil is a limited resource right I mean
like you know like Bitcoin in fact the
core the you know the thing that makes
Commodities valuable is that they're
scarce and attention did not turn out to
be scarce attention turned out to be
nearly infinite and the scale of
platforms like Google and Twitter meant
that even a publisher that got an
enormous amount of eyeballs and
attention like BuzzFeed
couldn't support quality journalism on
it you talk at the beginning of the book
about Jonah and I think it's his college
roommate they're kind of always making
these uh two dollar bets right and and
you perfectly laid out where uh he I
think accidentally went viral early in
the uh 2000s yeah and then his buddies
like I bet you can't do that again and
then you're like for the next 20 years
he tried to figure that out and so it
begs this question of like the dress it
sounds almost like uh it wasn't
engineered right like you guys were just
like oh this is cool we don't actually
have an answer like let's see kind of
what the audience does like post it and
it just explodes versus maybe the
threads or some of this other like what
I would consider like viral engineered
content where people very much sit down
and say I am going to create a piece of
viral content and that means it needs
you know aspect a or aspect b or aspect
C I'm gonna post it at a certain time on
this platform I'm gonna get my friends
to retweet it like that feels very
different than just like we posted a
picture of a dress and it exploded or
those two things changing because of the
way the algorithms work is it like
people now are caught on to the viral
threads and so the dress thing still
works how do you think about engineered
verse not it's funny because it BuzzFeed
when I was there and all through media
there are sort of two kinds of people
you know there are people who think okay
I have a piece of content and
and if I adjust these seven elements of
it it will go viral and then there are
people who are just like whoa this is so
cool I bet everybody else will think so
and I do think that media that
ultimately the winners are the second
kind because it is this because because
part of what makes the most interesting
most compelling things interesting
compelling is there's something
surprising something you couldn't have
predicted something weird and human and
like and the thing in the version of it
that's micro engineered
oh we you know never quite reaches that
that said but you know I think you can
develop okay if you are a person type A
you can also develop a passion for
things and get better at the actual
substance and if you were a person type
B
at BuzzFeed in particular was full of
people who were just good at the
internet they weren't hyper analytical
about it but they swam in those Waters
it's like you're really good at English
grammar not because you studied English
grammar because you're fluent in English
and I think like for people who live on
the internet and get great and I think
the people who are
the people who are best for better and
worse and making viral content like say
president Donald Trump it's not because
he like made a study of the seven
aspects it's because he just knows it
yeah it's like intuition almost to a
degree and really yeah gets it
um so we've got BuzzFeed on one side and
we've got Gawker on the other side uh
kind of in the book and these two uh
Tales if you will I think if you went on
the street and you ask people who pay
attention but maybe aren't inside the
media uh there's a generalization that
like BuzzFeed is like a positive uh
place that's like cool and they have the
listicles and like maybe some people
think it's like kind of like Dumber
content when it was really going viral
right but it's like very much positive
oriented and I think that they think
about it as like hey they don't really
do harm Gawker on the other hand I think
people again generalization would be
like oh those people are constantly
tearing people down and there's like
some negativity associated with it Etc
I'm not saying whether those are fair I
think that's true I think if you ask
people who worked at those places that's
how they said BuzzFeed slogan or when I
got there was no haters
um then yeah I like could be dumb and
and gawkers believed in what they would
call a kind of Ruthless honesty and you
know when they were like they started
they were like a little blog
whatever young women in New York who
would like Infiltrate The Conde Nast
cafeteria and write about how ridiculous
it was which was sort of like
genuinely kind of harm not like harmless
fun and you know picking on much bigger
more powerful institutions that that you
deserve to be poked at
and I do think that but there were these
two very different philosophies of like
what is the internet going to be like
like Jonah who founded BuzzFeed really
thought as people start to like share
things in public on social media they're
going to share positive stuff that makes
them look good I mean we definitely had
a specific theory that there's no way
people are going to share divisive
political content because it makes you
look like a crazy person like who would
do that that did not turn out to be a
true theory
um and Gawker had this other approach
which was that the thing the internet
can really do is say the things that you
would never say before to like the you
know just to like journalists you should
talk to a journalist about their story
and they're really fun and interesting
to talk to and they give you all this
gossip and then you read the story and
it's really boring and Gawker was going
to be like no we're going to say the
stuff that we say to each other in bars
but not
but but not in person I mean it turns
out sometimes you don't say that stuff
because it's incredibly malicious or
mean and as Gawker grew more powerful
and more of a cultural Force suddenly
it's less fun in games and it's more
like this big scary cultural you know
publisher is attacking random civilians
and I think they didn't I mean I
definitely have felt this I'm sure you
felt this if you start immediate being
and it's little and you're a weirdo
Outsider and then suddenly you're kind
of a powerful player and it's a weird
adjustment to realize like oh suddenly I
have power and that comes with some
responsibility and I think Gawker
accumulated all this power and reach and
scale and audience and never quite got
its head around that that puts you in a
different position and you're no longer
the kid throwing spitballs in the back
of the class it's interesting because
um I didn't understand this uh kind of
phenomenon if you will until uh when I
first started writing on the internet it
was very much like if you're punching
you can only punch up right like there's
literally no one below you because
you're you're on the floor totally I
remember that time like literally there
is no punching down because literally
there's no one below you um but as you
get bigger audiences and it's not even
necessarily like more power I actually
think just like size of audience right
yes that equates somewhat to power but
like even if people don't even care that
is power yeah and they're just you know
kind of listening or whatever somebody
once said to me you know once an email
crosses a certain uh size of audience
like you'd be the number one article on
a cnbc.com every single day if that was
listed as just an article not an email
newsletter or you know take a tweet how
many Impressions it gets or whatever and
so they were like again that doesn't
mean that like you should go and do that
that doesn't mean that it's a
replacement for that stuff it's just
it's different type of content but to
give you a sense of like comparing
audience sizes like you very quickly can
accumulate a large audience on these
other platforms and so if we go back to
this idea of like buzzfeeding Gawker
when BuzzFeed started to go more into
like I'll call like the serious
journalism it almost felt like virality
was yeah that's why that's when I got
there that was sort of my job exactly
and it felt like virality was really the
way to grow an audience and then it
almost felt like okay now we have to get
serious and like build a business we
have to actually do real journalism like
all that type of stuff is that something
that now in hindsight knowing everything
you know about what worked with it work
etc A playbook that you think people
will follow or do you feel like um you
know when you start the company today it
doesn't seem like you're like oh let's
go viral right it actually seems like
you're like no let's do like great work
from day one and build an audience that
has like a different brand promise than
maybe what BuzzFeed had in the early
totally
yeah I mean I think it's you know if
people want to find sort of like big
sweeping generalizations about the media
business and as you know it's just like
a weird hard business and there are lots
of different corners and I think it's
worth understanding with these big viral
companies that grew so big raised so
much money hired so many people BuzzFeed
advice probably the biggest like here's
what they were here's what we were
thinking which was that in the 1980s
some entrepreneurs rolled cable lines
out across the country and rolled wires
into people's homes and to get people to
adopt them they needed MTV they needed
CNN and they knew from the start that
they needed to pay a huge share of the
money they were taking in to MTV to CNN
to ESPN to get people to look at these
you know to turn on the television to
plug them in and the core of that Cable
business model was there's Distributors
with who own the wires there's media
companies who own who who create the
content and there's got to be some
Financial Arrangement where everybody
gets rich or the whole thing doesn't
work
um
and the theory that Vice and BuzzFeed
and others were operating under
fundamentally was there's this new form
of distribution
it's Facebook it's snap it's Twitter
it's Pinterest and as those guys compete
with each other as they compete with
everything else in the world just like
cable they're gonna start hiring media
companies to make the content for them
they're not going to depend on user
generated content forever
now you can argue about whether that was
totally delusional or whether things
just didn't break that way but they did
not break that way and the reason you
see these companies going out of
business is there are a lot of reasons
there's a lot of mismanagement we did
lots of stupid stuff but the fundamental
bad the fundamental thing that people
were putting in hundreds of the company
investors were putting hundreds of
millions of dollars into those companies
was that bet
and I think
that's just the notion that you're going
to build your company as a supplier of
content to a social platform that will
somehow pay you that that would be
insane to try to do today and so instead
I think what most what really all cross
media people are doing is trying to find
an audience who's really interested in
what you're doing and building a
one-to-one relationship with them that
isn't mediated by some platform
um yeah and so but that's a that's not a
business where you can reach a billion
people on your first day either talk
about the age of disinformation what
what's uh fascinating to me is like uh
we're talking about virality and the
dress is awesome like I remember
debating it with people and being like I
don't give a about this dress but
like if you want my opinion and you got
opinion like you know let's duke it out
and see uh who's right who's wrong
um but when that all of a sudden becomes
something that's much more either
serious or could uh potentially harm
people or uh almost program people's
minds like I think a lot about like the
algorithms especially on social media
um I recently tweeted and was like you
either train the algorithm to show you
the things you want or it programs you
right like there's only two oh yes here
and I think one thing about young people
now it's so interesting is that people
who use tick tock are hyper aware that
they are programming Tick Tock to feed
them what they you know and that their
behavior is being mirrored but no what
you said about the dress is really
interesting the thing about the dress is
it was incredibly divisive that's what
made it so fun was some people you know
two-thirds of people thought it was I
think white and gold and one third
thought it was blue and black they were
correct by the way but um the uh but it
was divisive and people argued about it
it was divisive in the most harmless and
sweet way you can imagine but it was
divisive and the reason it went so big
on Facebook was Facebook had you know
when Facebook wasn't trying to elect
Donald Trump or elect Joe Biden or
whatever Facebook was trying to you know
you'd been spending 14 minutes and they
wanted you to spend 15 minutes and the
way that they could get used to stick
was quote unquote engaging content and
they were running all these experiments
but what you know how do we find the
most engaging stuff and for a while it
was like well if you share this that's
an indication that it engaged you and
you'll somebody else will be engaged
with it but then it turned out there was
all this stuff that was like Hillary
Clinton has been replaced by a body
double
and like you would share that because
like LOL kind of and also because you
hate Hillary Clinton or whatever but not
because you read it and liked it and
actually it was garbage content it was
an embarrassment for them and so they
thought okay that doesn't quite work
okay the way we will really detect
engagement is by comments like forget
the shares and the likes the really
engaging stuff is the stuff that people
comment on
now it turned out to think people would
comment on most in the world is like I
post like a super racist Meme and then
you write you're a racist and then I
write no you're a racist and then we
have like a really elevated conversation
like that for a while the algorithm says
wow this is incredibly meaningful
engagement we're going to show this to
everyone on the entire platform and
particularly particularly racially
divisive content spread like wildfire on
Facebook
and so when you take again uh maybe
racially divisive is uh I think many
people in society hopefully most people
would say hey that's wrong right we
don't want that type of stuff being the
dominant uh content that people are
being consumed I don't think the
platforms are like hey this is the type
of content we want to be promoting or
any of that type of stuff so let's just
assume everyone's a good actor right for
the the purposes well I would say the
platforms had these ideas about well we
don't we don't want to look at the
details of the content we just want to
measure its performance and so they were
very reluctant to just like look at
a horrible argument just an obviously
terrible destructive screaming match
about race and say look this is bad
like they were just reluctant just to
say that which any normal person could
say but anyway other they got there okay
so if you take that and you now look at
let's take an election right I think
that's probably the one that uh at least
people in the you know modern day they
point to and they're like okay
regardless of what side you come out on
on uh political affiliations or whatever
like there was a whole bunch of stuff
that happened in 2016 and in 2020 and
likely will happen going into 2024. in
terms of uh the use of these platforms
we saw recently that uh Ron DeSantis is
supposedly going to make his
announcement with Elon Musk on Twitter
some people love that idea some people
hate that oh you can already see the the
wheels are in motion here is it just
like this is the trajectory and there's
no going back like is the genie kind of
out of the bottle on a lot of this stuff
and whether the platforms actually want
to change or not like they're addicted
people are addicted and it is just this
game of attention even if we're going
down a path that like may not be best
for society or for individuals like
mental health type stuff
you know I could be really wrong but I
think actually the platforms are
fundamentally in Decline like I don't
know about you I've been I spend very
little time on Facebook these days I
mean I'm on there once in a while to
check on somebody's birthday and when I
go on it's re it's cute animal videos
and the reels that's how they're trying
to keep people and they are cute like my
I saw a really cute video of a dog the
other day when I was on there but like I
don't I mean I think Facebook was 10
years ago seven years ago Facebook was
this like centrally culturally relevant
force and I think it is clearly not
anymore
Twitter I think you know musk is trying
I think it was already kind of falling
apart and for me again like just as a
long time power user love Twitter it no
longer does the job if I open Twitter I
just want to know what's happening today
I'm a journalist like is there a crisis
in the Middle East like what's going on
I still find Twitter pretty fun and
interesting because it's like everyone's
screaming at each other about Twitter
but it no longer does the job of what is
happening like I go to the Drudge Report
and to the New York Times
and I think Twitter again like not that
it's not gonna remain a real place in a
real business and a real whatever but
it's not a centrally cult it's not as
culturally Central as it was five years
ago I mean the leading indicator that
which musk actually noticed is that
celebrities have all left celebrities
used to be on Twitter they're not
anymore like it's just it's not it's and
I think you know there are spaces I
think Reddit is the best example of a
network that kind of like stabilized
found a place in society nobody thinks
that like America is a run on Reddit but
it's actually pretty great and
interesting and useful
um I think Twitter could easily become
that Facebook could become some version
that I lost my dog actually recently and
the first thing I did was go to the
neighborhood Facebook group and somebody
had found the dog it was great for that
but I didn't elect the president United
States
um and I know so I actually think I
think that moment of us all having our
brains melted by social media is kind of
drawn to a close and I think it's
basically because we're all sick of it
like I think
that's why so I have this question for
you you have no clue that I'm going to
ask you this but I thought this would be
a great way to take everything that
you've learned about virality platforms
content human psychology like just
everything in your life right and boil
it down to if you were running for
president of the United States today
where would you go post content like
where would your focus go would it be in
online like to the twitters to Facebooks
and those platforms would it be like
dances on Tick Tock would it be you know
hey forget the online stuff like I'm
just gonna go do rallies in person like
how do you think about running for
president and it appears is all about
like take a message and get it out to as
many people in the most convincing way
possible so then on a certain date they
go and they vote for you right and like
yeah I was actually I'm honored to
announce my presidential campaign on
your show that was that was the plan you
know people have been people often call
me and they say band you ought to run
for um yeah I mean I think you know
the politics is kind of the is the media
business
and I mean I think and I so I mean and
for years has been increasingly
um what do you mean by that I mean I
think and I think I mean just so you
know that you're putting out images and
ideas and videos and audio and you're
competing for attention with people like
you and me but I remember I first
noticed this covering the Obama campaign
for Politico and we were making these
dumb videos where we like interviewed
each other about politics and about the
Obama campaign was making vastly better
really beautiful and Slick videos and it
was like oh my God we're competing with
the people we're covering and they're
beating us this is terrible and now
that's just sort of the world we live in
but so I think that a lot of that same
kind of thinking is going on in these
campaigns I mean
Republicans and Democrats are very
different
if you're running for the Democratic
nomination there's a series of sort of
establishment Gatekeepers like the New
York Times you want to impress if you're
running for the Republican nomination
you want to show particularly this
post-trump era that you are not part of
the establishment you want to have
fights with the establishment you want
to show how independent you are of the
establishment so for Trump like going on
CNN and attacking Caitlin Collins is
like the ideal version of that for
Rhonda Sanders
you know I think going on Twitter is
sort of his version of that and doing it
with musk um I mean I think the big
question now and I could be totally
wrong is
you know because it's really I mean it's
again it's like for now right now it's
question about Republican primary voters
do Republican primary voters you know
they watch television they read Twitter
they see that people are mad about
um transgender rights they see that
people are mad about Bud Light and
something something they see that people
are mad about um
a bunch of things that have no zero
impact on their daily lives and I think
there is a big question of do you you
know do you run a campaign that is about
these cultural issues that like I don't
know like I send my kids to public
school in New York City and this stuff
never comes up and I I would assume that
if you were in Iowa it is very unlikely
that your school is spending a ton of
time talking about race and gender like
it just I just think it's
it's a huge part of what you see on Fox
News what you see on Twitter and a very
small part of people's lives
um and I think there is this thing where
Rhonda status is making a bet that these
Twitter these issues that are really
only exist when you look at the internet
are really going to compel people and
they might and I think Trump always I
mean the core issue that he ran on was
immigration which was not a fake issue
and wasn't something that was mostly on
Twitter was something that Republican
voters were Furious about had been
Furious about for years
for you know sometimes because they were
racist sometimes because they were mad
about the declining incomes of
electricians I mean a range of reasons
right some kind of disturbing and some
totally legitimate
um but I guess I mean maybe I am really
naive but I do think that
you gotta find at some level the
candidate who's going to win is gonna be
talking about stuff that matters in
people's daily lives not stuff that only
matters when they turn on their screens
I I do wonder how much
um of the world is like a mirror to the
internet we talk a lot about like these
pla you know Twitter's a mirror of
society you know will be something you
hear people talk about but like Obama I
think actually was the first one you
know he had the uh um kind of the
button-down shirt with the rolled up
sleeves and he was trying to he was
still presidential but he was trying to
be a little bit more relatable I think
and kind of uh connect with people and
you've seen
um to some degree like across Society
people have become like less serious
right and you kind of see this
degradation of seriousness
um and I always wonder like how much of
that is driven by the media versus like
the media is just reporting on like what
they're seeing and so it is this like
reinforcing thing and maybe like the
most uh kind of obvious example is like
Mark Zuckerberg with the hoodie made it
cool and like that was like free reign
for an entire you know industry basic to
like suits like why would we wear suits
right and so you gotta get this Mo this
movement in that direction
and it was signal I mean for you know
well you know I think I mean I think
it's all signaling and it's sort of I
mean you know Donald Trump wanted to
signal that he was going back to like a
sort of 1950s idea of America and part
of that was wearing a suit and having a
wife who'd been a model and his perfect
family staring up adoringly at him or
whatever like I think it's all signaling
policy I think Republicans mostly are
very buttoned at like look like man
almost all mostly men from a while ago
was being stuck out jaws and adoring
wives who don't necessarily work because
that's the sort of that's what the
values they're trying to project in a
you know in a substantive way I think
it's always signaling I mean
yeah I remember it's some and I actually
I covered the Obama campaign and there
was a point and maybe it was the
financial crisis when they decided he
had to wear a tie and it was like a big
thing so he didn't really Wear Ties I'm
sure he ever worn ties and they were
like all right now you have to look
presidential and that involves wearing a
tie and it is funny because people
mostly comment on women politicians
appearances and everybody gets annoyed
when you do but of course these choices
they make are incredibly deliberate and
are and and do sort of intend to Signal
what they're up to I don't know I mean
there was
crazy moment I remember this Kamala
Harris was on the cover of Vogue and
they put a this very informal looking
picture of her wearing sneakers and her
team freaked out and I think her family
got mad and they said it was kind of
racist to do that and not in keeping
with the Dignity of the office which I
thought was insane it's like no no like
you the person like
the best the reason that people liked
her when they did was that she felt like
this relatable normal person not in the
Dignity of the office of the vice
president but I do think these are
choices that politicians take incredibly
seriously and think about a lot
go back to this idea of the competition
because we're talking about like the
politicians right is that still true in
the business world as well like do you
think that the journalists that you all
employ or journalists at the New York
Times or you know name your your
publication and then like I don't know
maybe take like the sub stack writer who
covers a similar uh you know beat if you
want I'll kind of put that in air quotes
because I don't know if you guys would
uh agree that it's a beat or not right
yeah but and then also maybe take like
the poster on Twitter right like
yeah or the or like autism Capital right
like or this sort of Twitter Rando who's
incredibly wired in and breaks news no I
mean I think it's a
yeah I mean I think you have to see
yourself as competing with and talking
to everybody all the time when you're
like uh and I don't think I mean I'm not
a big fan of the notion that there's
like this thing called a capital J
journalist that is different from
another person who is good at getting
information and ideas like there's I
think when journalists pretend that they
have some like special set of skills
because they went to journalism school
like that's not true and eventually
people figure that out
um so and I think the big thing that
media companies are wrestling with right
now is
you know if you're the Wall Street
Journal you are used to treating
hundreds and hundreds of journals it's
sort of interchangeable cogs in a
machine that produce Wall Street Journal
articles
um but you have an audience increasingly
that does want to connect to individuals
and by the way like not all those
journalists are as good as each other
and a few of them are huge stars but
you've sort of hidden that like you know
that but you're like not letting the
reader in on that and so certainly at
samaphor like our whole theory of the
case is that there's a kind of
journalist for whom
doing your own sub stack thing is not
natural it's like it's kind of just I am
it's like people who do a lot of
reporting who break a lot of news who
get into some of the big legal and
political fights over the news they
break do kind of need and want a
newsroom need and want some legal
support it's not I think substack has
been great for commentators and analysts
but you don't see some you need a team
sometimes the story is going to take a
couple weeks and you're going to need to
vanish and if somebody else write your
newsletter for a couple of weeks like
it's it's a kind of Journalism that's
harder to do is it's not really a solo
thing but those reporters do have voices
do have ideas do you have things they
want to say do covet that direct
connection with the audience that you
get in contemporary media and you don't
get at the Wall Street Journal of the
New York Times and so for people like
for me for um Liz Hoffman who to my mind
was like maybe the best reporter at the
Wall Street Journal who we hired to
cover Finance for us
you know we're trying to say come to
Summer before you can have the best of
both worlds you can have a great
Newsroom and lead in the kind of
infrastructure of a newsroom but we also
understand that the way media works now
is the audience wants to hear from a
human being not from this faceless brand
and so I think we're trying to
to build that system in some sense build
a kind of a platform for that kind of
journalist
what I find fascinating about what you
all are doing is not only the types of
people you're trying to hire but also
even some of the form factors like I
think it was Liz actually I saw
um she did an interview and it's like
almost like text messages right yeah
kind of back back and forth like talk a
little bit as to
um you know you could just post it as an
interview right it was hey first of all
we are we are very we are very authentic
when they're text messages they are
actually text messages but I think
people really feel I mean I mean I feel
like there's this weird like opacity to
a lot of media like you read an article
in the New York Times and there's some
ideas in it and there's some assertions
I'm like which ones are the reporter's
opinion which ones are their editor's
opinion which ones are the policies the
New York Times which are just
indisputable facts it's not totally
clear and that is and I think that
there's a kind of an uncanny valley
there and so we are obsessed with kind
of transparency which isn't to say kind
of old-fashioned objectivity like I am a
robot who has no point of view and I'm
just delivering you the facts no one no
one believes that
um so if we but so it does mean like if
I I love text messages because you know
with a video interview or a profile the
reader can Wonder like oh did you edit
it like how what really you know what
was like what's the real thing even with
the transcript with text messages what I
love about text actually like you see
exactly what I see there's no additional
context like it's kind of cool that way
um and then in our articles we also you
know stylized kind of deliberate way
label the sections like here's the news
and here is Ben's opinion and like
Anthony thinks I'm an idiot and has a
different opinion we're going to stick
that in too and and label it and so yeah
I think that's that's something you know
people seem to like right now when you
take this uh kind of unique way of
presenting the news how do you think
about Distributing it obviously you guys
have the newsletters
um what's kind of the long game is it
like okay let's letters up and running
and then we can eventually like get
people back to you know own an operated
site podcast like just talk about like
distribution in general I mean I would
love your advice it's such a weird world
right now because it's like the whole
social media social media has just
massively kind of receded though all the
traffic that used to come from places
like Facebook is gone or a lot of it but
nothing has really replaced it and so
you know for us newsletters are a great
way to reach people and it's you know
great individualized way to reach people
with something that they've signed up
for that they want if they don't open it
you can take them off the list like it's
just very natural
um but also emails this technology from
the 1990s like I can't believe that the
final form of Internet journalism will
be email the web is important for us we
get you know a lot of readers there but
is not what it once was isn't the
central pillar of an organization we do
a lot of events it's a huge part of what
we do and that's I do think post covet
it feels like there's this huge appetite
for it that's been very very successful
for us we do you know we produce great
videos and or you know but not at a huge
scale and they're thinking about audio
they haven't just didn't want to bite
off more than we could chew at launch
honestly but I do think audio fits into
that kind of direct you know way of
reaching an audience directly and
talking to people directly but it it it
does feel I'm sort of like okay what's
next like you know like I think like sub
Stacks like oh is it can we build this
world inside sub stack with notes
there's this thing artifact Apple news
is out there I mean there's a it's a
really interesting strange part of why I
wanted to start a new thing it feels
like a moment when everything is
changing again
when you see what is working
um what are the things that like maybe
people don't realize have more impact
than they do right so like the
newsletter is to me
just watching what you guys are doing
like okay obviously the newsletters are
working right yeah but are there other
things that you have discovered as you
guys have tried different things and
kind of launching this that you're
saying hey you know this works much
better than people maybe would think
so I would say I've only been doing this
for six months and so no one should like
you're supposed to be next time it was a
New York Times for two years before
we've kind of throwing stones into
everybody else's glass houses writing
about media
um I mean I would say events are the
thing that have been surprisingly
successful for us
um how do those work you you're getting
just like uh a single person for an
interview is it like no what we've been
doing is getting you know a huge lineup
of Music Makers to like when the IMF and
World Bank met in Washington we had this
world economy Summit where Poppy Harlow
from CNN came and interviewed Lil
Brainerd by this top economic advisor
there was a bunch of CEOs and big
government officials and made a ton of
news lots of people came sponsors wanted
to be associated with it because it was
this sort of central conversation about
these huge issues so we've done that
that kind of stuff and that's been yeah
it's just been I think you know
it's all the execution you have to
actually get incredibly interesting
people to then and then push them on
stage to say interesting stuff but
that's been
really good for us
um
you know
yeah but but I guess
I mean my the other thing and this is
this is
a silly thing to say because it's so
obvious but in my part of the journalism
business Scoops are the coin of the
realm like it's called news you gotta
have news and so you know for we've
broken a lot of news we broke I think
maybe the biggest story we broke was
that Microsoft was about to invest in
chat CPT
um in open AI but but and a lot of
Stories on hey a lot of finance a lot
out of Washington and that's I mean
ultimately
that's how you break through and just
get people like even people have never
heard of you or like hey what is that
thing so so we focus a lot on breaking
news it's not it's that's not a um
you know it's not sort of nobody's gonna
come and come back and back just because
you're randomly breaking news but but it
is a way to introduce yourself to people
how do you see the relationship with
sources changing when you know you're at
BuzzFeed Politico New York Times now you
have your own thing if you just were
like a suit Anonymous person on Twitter
yeah you had an account like how do you
think about uh are they willing to tell
you more less do they care where you are
versus it's you
it's really different I mean it used to
be
well I think the biggest change is that
sources always have the Opera the op the
option of just going Direct
right it used to be if you were a
political figure
and you had a story to tell you
basically had to go to the New York
Times or the Washington Post and one of
two or three reporters and you and they
had all this power and you and you would
kiss their ass all the time in the hopes
that you know when you had something
that they would write it in a nice way
um and now you can just tweet it and
like if you want and and what why would
you take your news to the New York Times
and it and it has changed it really has
changed that power Dynamic I mean it
also
it was not the highest form of
Journalism to rewrite people's press
releases so who kind of who cares but um
but it but yeah I think that the
you know the gate I mean this is one of
a million ways in which Gatekeepers used
to exercise so much power and it is like
it's it's sort of dumb I mean it's so
obvious that it almost feels dumb to say
but it used to be if you wanted to reach
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people there were two ways to do that
you could purchase and own a printing
press or you could have the rights to a
broadcast tower those were the two ways
there wasn't a third and like it's it's
sort of and then the people who
controlled those two if you count radio
three like in pieces of infrastructure
where the people who controlled
information and when there was like a
coup in a country you know in the fall
of the Soviet Union the people where
people were killed in the 91 when the
Soviet Union's falling apart were around
television Towers because in places like
Latvia and Lithuania the people the
Freedom Fighters were defending the
television Towers against the tanks
because that was and it's like hard to
remember now that that that that that
that was the case because now it's wide
open but I still think there's sort of a
impulse in some of these Legacy Media
companies that like were The Gatekeepers
all information runs through us it
doesn't exist if we don't publish it and
that's just so disconnected from the
reality we all live in now
talk to me about funding of these media
businesses I think that there's kind of
two interesting things right so uh you
all raise money
um Sam Beckman free was a part of that
you guys kind of got into that whole
thing you just today we I would say I'm
in a great mood today because we closed
the book on Sam bankman freed we raised
a new Round We repurchased his interest
all right so explain kind of uh maybe
like initial fundraising and how you
thought about you know where where do
you go find funding for a media
organization like who's even interested
in funding this type of stuff and then
how you think about like okay now I've
got to uh go and raise more capital and
I know Henry Cava it's Jerry Yang like a
bunch of these kind of you know very
well-known people are investing so
you're asking like what kind of lunatic
would invest in media in this day and
age well not only what kind but also
just like how do you think about it
right because like although people don't
look at it this way like it's very much
a double opt-in like you want certain
people to invest right and then you also
uh want to make sure that or you need to
go find people who want to invest and so
like how do you get the double opt-in
there yeah I mean you know I think I
would one thing is when we were BuzzFeed
you know we had this idea that I talked
about earlier on cable that this could
be a huge business that could return
massively and actually had we sold to
Disney for 600 million dollars in 2014 I
suppose it would have to those early
investors
um who were Venture capitalists and
recent Horowitz was an investor I mean I
go back and I think you know what media
is like a media is certainly not news in
particular is not a business that is
going to 10x in three years and give you
a sort of venture-like return
it's a thing that's important for the
world and if you and if you are good
experienced operators
and work incredibly hard can be a pretty
good business you know can be a
you know a profitable business with a
good return but you need people who
believe in the mission who and believe
in the missions degree that they're not
gonna that they're gonna resist the
temptation to try to use their
investment to metal with the content and
it and then you and and ideally and I
think in math context it's good to have
a lot like a diverse group of investors
and ideologically diverse group of
investors so you're not you know so this
is that they understand that there's
sort of an arm's life relationship they
have to be and they have to be patient
and then the other thing I mean I think
part of I mean my own experience right
was that this sort of crazy ride at
BuzzFeed and so coming to semaphore
it was really I mean the part of the
reason that I went into business with my
partner Justin Smith no relation is he's
really like the best news business
operator of Our Generation he was CEO of
Bloomberg before that he returned the
Atlantic around series of very
successful senior roles in the in the
news business and there's this Quirk of
the news business that has been such a
bad business for so long that the ranks
of Executives at news businesses are not
always the best and the brightest like
would you want to sell ads in a
newspaper or would you want to sell like
used cars you might prefer to sell used
cars just in terms of your comp and so
as the news businesses declined it and
been in kind of this awful death spiral
for years like the quali like the
quality of Talent on the business side
is very uneven and so you know it's a
really hard business and the difference
between great execution and
you know not great execution is huge and
it's a tough enough business that you
it's not a place where you can just kind
of come in and like put your hands out
and collect money
um I mean that's probably not true
anywhere but I definitely
you know wanted to build like a grown-up
sustainable business around news when
you think about uh what that looks like
is this something where uh you know Vice
obviously just filed for bankruptcy and
like they hired hundreds if not
thousands of people at one point is that
like the type of business today or do
you think it's more like 50 people and
you kind of punch above your weight in
terms of employees versus you know reach
and monetization
yeah and I think if somebody goes back
to the talent stuff we were talking
about you know in a world where people
want to feel very connected to an
individual you don't want to hire 100
business reporters you want to hire one
or two really great ones
um
and you know you can maybe in other
verticals and other niches you can hire
one or two people but you're not looking
to
um
yeah I mean both of necessity but also
in reality it doesn't make sense to try
to the goal isn't to grow infinitely
um but I think a lot of our companies
have looked at these big Industrial Age
news companies and said well that's kind
of the model you want to have hundreds
and hundreds of journalists and I think
that's
that's both not how people connect to
Media now and not an incredibly
irresponsible way to build a business
you know you want to race to
profitability and then you can start
thinking about growth
last thing uh that I've got on this is
um in the book you talk about Breitbart
and I know you worked at Politico and
like there's like specialization right
and so there's like political uh type
content but then there's like political
left political right there there's
um you know you can go across these
sectors even if you look at um inside of
some of the financial markets like you
have very specific viewpoints and things
like that it seems like you guys aren't
really going after that like you're
you're taking a stance maybe on like
what type of media company needs to
exist you know you talk about like
meeting the moment
but it doesn't seem like you're
specializing on any one topic or any
kind of viewpoint yeah we're certainly
not trying to kind of I mean I just
think that the there obviously is a huge
business in serving committed right-wing
partisans or committed left-wing
partisans
and that's not the business and but also
there's a lot of people doing that and I
think that the the Dynamics of the Trump
era and of the sort of new subscription
businesses pulled a lot of mainstream
Outlets into a kind of resistance
cheerleading posture in the Trump moment
that they're kind of trying to dial back
from and I I mean I do think that
you know you I think that it's often
framed as there's a debate between our
our job is to be totally objective just
the facts ma'am journalists with no
opinions or our job is to stand on the
barricades against Donald Trump or for
Donald Trump or whatever
and I guess I I don't think that's
actually what anybody's asking like I
don't touch or anything like I don't
think any reader is saying please lie to
me if that's what I want I mean I think
people are saying like
we want a human being who's with a point
of view who could be wrong who has the
humility to acknowledge by the way they
could be wrong and he's bringing new
facts and who's helping to navigate this
very chaotic complicated landscape
um I think there's a big I just think
there's a big demand for that
your new book traffic genius rivalry and
delusion the billion dollar race to go
viral when somebody reads this uh how
much of this did you write for
entertainment purposes as to like
telling the stories versus like there's
a message specifically that you want to
get across you know I'm basically a
reporter and I kind of came out of I got
to the New York Times in 2020 and just
think and and just thought what the hell
did I just go through like what was the
last 15 years and mostly and I did not I
mean I think there are lessons in that
about about certainly about the business
and about the sort of shape of American
politics and global politics but mostly
it really is it tries trying to be the
story like it's sort of the crazy origin
story of this bizarre moment we're
living in
uh the fact that you say you're
basically a reporter uh is almost like a
qualification that you have I mean I'm
not a deep I mean I mean I'm not it's
not meant to be a sort of like six
principles of How To Succeed in Business
yes although you can hit sort of the
opposite
there are many lessons it's I think a
good way to put it yeah but they're not
all like positive lessons yeah maybe
lessons of what not to do uh Ben listen
thank you thank you so much for uh
taking the time to do this so traffic
genius rivalry and delusion in the
billion dollar race to go viral if you
haven't read it yet I highly suggest you
go pick it up we'll have the link in the
description and then Ben talk a little
bit maybe just in terms of if people
want to check out what you guys are
doing now at semaphore uh where should
we send them are there a specific
newsletter or a website I mean go to go
to semaphore.com and check it out but I
do think for for your listeners in
particular Liz Hoffman to my mind the
best business reporter at the Wall
Street Journal came over and joined us
is just dominating these big stories
about about Wall Street and we've also
just been covering the hell out of AI
read albergate who is is best known in
his life for having broken the Lance
Armstrong story but he's been is you
know digging really deep on sort of the
you know the partly like the untold
backstory of this AI moment he had this
incredible story the other day about how
Elon Musk you know who had been a huge
investor in the first version of openai
had this previously unreported
confrontation with Sam Altman where musk
basically said this company's failing
you're falling behind Google you should
um I need to I Elon Musk and the only
man who can save this company and should
take over right now and Altman and the
other Founders sort of fought him bad
fought back and musk walked away with a
billion dollars and Incredibly high
stakes interesting stuff happening right
now in that world so that's our Tech
newsletter that I hope that I think your
audience might like I read multiple
things you guys put out and I really
enjoy it so keep up the great work and
the book is fantastic as well I uh we'll
wait for your next ACT and then we'll do
this again once uh once you get
something else to talk about but thanks
Anthony this is really generous to be to
have man